Project two is a fun project.
Honestly to me,
it's one of the easiest projects
through the Nano Degree program.
And I say that just because
the associated class
helps students get started
with writing JSON objects.
And for those of you working on project
two, the JSON object kind of related
to how they'll be defining object for
project three.
There we go.
So the first section is pretty clear.
Make sure you have some information,
real or fake, about yourself or
someone else.
You have their bio, their contact info and
the project gets you started along
a really good path if you just go and
read the readMe.
It's associated,
it's going to help you done.
Just read this part, tells you exactly
what you need for each of those parts.
The second part of it has
to do with functions and
it says all the resume functions should be
built with modular functions.
Now what is the big
deal with modularity.
Basically the word modular,
itself, means something that
can be broken down into parts.
It separates your code into independent
parts which can be put together
very easily.
And a way to think about
this is modular sofas.
You can buy it in individual pieces and
just piece them together.
You can have just a single sofa and
then add on a double one to it,
depending on how long your living your
room is, I guess, and your style.
>> That's very important, right?
>> It can also help
when there are multiple
people working on the same project and
each person can work on parts of it.
And you can put them
together afterwards.
So each member would flush out a module
and when they work perfectly, by that
you would also be checking on small
snippets of code to work the right way.
And once that happens you can just
assemble them together in one project.
Now, it can also help extend things.
So, say right now I have a function or
code that only does things A, B, and C.
I can add modules to it so
that it can do C, D, and E.
And in case of the interactive resume,
maybe you just want to start
with one thing, say your bio, and
make sure that works perfectly fine.
And then come back and add a little
bit of module for your work.
And then your project.
So you can keep extending
it in a really easy way.
And that really helps debugging as well.
>> Yeah.
>> because you don't want to write all
your code, just to see a blank page
on your Chrome browser window.
You open it up and you don't know what
is going on, where you made the error.
So it's very convenient if you
want to build out part by part,
module by module.
So you want to build up your bio
section first, see if it renders, and
then go ahead with
the rest of the sections.
>> Just go piece by piece.
And I guess with that,
although we covered this in the class,
I would like to just show our students
how to go and define functions.
And talk about the difference
between function expression and
function declaration.
Let's just make sure that we
actually go in to Sublime and
tell Sublime that this is JavaScript.
Now something that I am
missing here is a semicolon.
This is called a function expression.
And it must come with semicolon
at the end of the curly braces.
It's really important with styling,
and styling your code in
a certain way is really important
to work with the Industry and
just work at industry standards.
There's another way to define
a function and we can just call it
this way, and
the code associated with go over there.
However in this case since it is a
function declaration, it should not have
a semicolon at the end of it.
That is an extra semicolon,
you don't need it.
So quickly, to remember, if there is
a var associated with your function,
it must have a semicolon.
If you don't have a var in you declaration or when you're
beginning to write your function,
you do not need to have
a semicolon in the end.
And then the way we would call each
of these functions is just by writing
thisFunction(), and
thisFunction2().
Again my semicolons are missing.
>> I just nudged Gauril.
>> [LAUGH] Semicolon.
So that's the way you
would define a function.
So make sure you understand
the difference between what
a function declaration versus
a function expression is.
The expression comes with var,
V-A-R associated with it
the declaration doesn't.
And when you have var
associated with a function,
have a semicolon, otherwise don't.
It's an extra semicolon
in your code reviews,
you will get pointed out on that little semicolon.
>> For sure [CROSSTALK], yeah.
What does encapsulating something mean?
It's to covering it up
into separate objects.
So, hold inside, or keep data pertaining
to a particular object with it.
And it also helps with modularity.
So, you don't have a function defined
there, and then it's associated.
If you are adding onto it, a function
that you're adding on in some other
place, so it helps with unspaghettifying
your code, if that word even exists.
>> Yeah, we can maybe show
them a quick example of
how to write a basic
structure of encapsulation.
So basically what you're doing is,
you're just wraping your data and
your functions together
within an object, right.
So this object is going to be able to
access all the data as well as
access the member functions.
So I can type up something
real quick in Sublime.
>> That's good and
I'll go share your screen.
Great!
So I'm screen sharing and right now
I'm going to give a JSON
object named person.
And what I'm going to do is,
I'm going to create a name attribute.
Oops I guess I forgot my parentheses.
>> They are quotes.
>> So I have a name property, and
then I assigned Poornima to it.
And then.
>> Do you want a comma, Poornima?
>> Yeah but
I'm just introducing [CROSSTALK].
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
And then what I do is I have
a person.display function defined here.
Whoops.
Whoops, whoops.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay, and then what
I'm going to do here is just say
console.log of person.name,
so semicolon [LAUGH].
And now how I can access, so
as you can see this person
object has a name attribute,
and that has my name assigned to it,
and it has a display function.
So, to call this function all
I have to do is say display.
>> Poonima, hang on.
>> Okay.
So I just showed you
encapsulate a function and
it's attribute within an object,
how do you call the object and
access these functions and
the attributes.
So that's what I did here and
you can extend this like Gary said.
I can add a role to this and say coach.
Yeah and I can add [CROSSTALK]
organization, okay, yeah.
>> Udacity.
So defining your function outside
of the object using dot notation.
The dot is like an apostrophe
in the English language.
So it's basically saying person's
display function is going to
console.log that person.name.
Now there is another way by
defining the display function,
and let's call it something else,
inside the object itself.
And to do that.
Okay I guess you all are seeing.
This screen.
Thank you I'm just going to go ahead and
keep delivering your responses,
as questions.
I guess we can go ahead and
Poornima can
you define the function
inside the person object.
So the way we would do that
is just have a function, and
let's call it functionTwo or something.
And you are missing a comma.
Okay and then function name,
functionTwo, and then colon.
And this would be the function
that you're telling it that this
property's actually a function, and
you have curly braces and your code.
And this time it might be console.log
the person's role, or something.
And then the way to actually call
this function is very similar
to the display one, and
you would still go person dot.
>> FunctionTwo.
>> And it will pull it for me.
>> [LAUGH] This is convenient.
>> FunctionTwo.
That's the way we'd be
calling that function.
So that basically is encapsulation.
To meet specifications,
you definitely want to have
your Google map that renders.
And the code for
it is given to you in your helper.js.
So you need to go and
uncomment that code.
And it should take the place or
location associated with wherever
you live or where you work or
where you got your education from,
and help you display it on the map.
That is the basic interactivity we do
expect to see to meet specifications.
Beyond that you can add many bars or
navigation bars.
Some sort of a skills chart that is
the one I have seen and enjoyed a lot.
>> I think that is called the navigation
bars are a part of Polymer.
So you can check that out.
And definitely for
exceeding specifications in that area,
I've seen some of them just
provide links to their contacts.
So wherever you provide contacts and
where you have your LinkedIn handle or
your twitter handle mentioned there,
what do you can do is you add
a hyperlink that will actually
take anyone who's looking at your
resume to your Twitter account or
your LinkedIn page or however.
So you can do that.
That is also definitely [CROSSTALK].
>> So something that I have seen and
enjoyed a lot, and
it had to do with going and
modifying the styling as well,
was when I hovered over a certain skill
or contact, it would change the color.
Or there was one where it would jump,
and
that I thought was particularly helpful
with the nanodegree because you do
have something of that
sort in your project five.
And while you all are far away from that
right now, it is something to consider.
So we love seeing projects
that exceed specifications.
So we encourage you to work on that.
>> And the next part also,
the artistic creativity,
that if you exceed in that you get
an overall Exceeds in your project.
Sometimes students overlook
that they have to go above and
beyond in both the sections to actually
exceed specifications in the project.
So, yeah, do you want to talk
about the artistic creativity?
[LAUGH]
>> Sure.
>> Okay.
>> So the artistic creativity
has basically got to do with
your layout in your CSS.
And we want you to have
fun with the project.
It doesn't necessarily mean that you
have to completely change the project.
We do love to see those projects, but
the basic expectation is that you change
your font, you change the layout, and
we'll show you
>> Font and colors,
because-
>> Font and color scheme.
[COUGH]
>> I think right now it's a shade of
gray and orange, that you used.
So yeah, go ahead.
You can alter colors and
change the layout of the page entirely.